Sans doute à peu près de la moitié des emplois dans l'économie.
De l'autre côté de cette ligne de démarcation,
nous avons tous les emplois qui nécessitent une capacité
perçue comme exclusivement humaine.
Nous pensons que ces emplois seront préservés.
Sur base de sur ce que je sais à propos du go,
et je pensais aussi que ces emplois être du bon côté de la ligne,
mais le fait que ce ne soit pas le cas, que Google ait résolu ce problème,
suggère que cette ligne va être très dynamique.
Elle va bouger.
et engloutir de plus en plus d'emplois et tâches
perçus actuellement comme étant préservés de l'automatisation.
L'autre idée clé à comprendre
est que cela n'affecte pas seulement les emplois peu rémunérés ou manuels,
ou des emplois effectués par des personnes avec relativement peu d'éducation.
De nombreuses preuves appuient le fait
que ces technologies escaladent l'échelle des compétences.
L'impact est déjà visible sur les emplois de spécialistes,
des tâches effectuées par les comptables par exemple,
les analystes financiers,
les journalistes,
les avocats, les radiologues et ainsi de suite.
Donc, les nombreuses hypothèses que nous formulons
sur le genre de professions, de tâches et d'emplois
qui verront leur avenir compromis par l’automatisation,
sont susceptibles de s’avérer erronées.
Quand nous analysons ces tendances,
elles nous montrent que nous pourrions très bien finir
avec un futur où un chômage important est la norme.
Ou au mieux,
nous pourrions faire face à un sous-emploi larvé et des salaires stagnants,
voire des salaires en baisse.
Bien sûr, les inégalités augmenteront.
Tout cela va entraîner une énorme pression sur la structure de la société.
Au-delà de tout ceci, il y a un problème économique fondamental,
qui se produit car l'emploi représente actuellement le principal mécanisme
de distribution des revenus, et donc du pouvoir d'achat
à tous ceux qui achètent les produits et les services que nous produisons.
Une économie de marché dynamique est possible
quand il y a beaucoup de consommateurs
capables d'acheter les produits et services qui sont produits.
Sans cela, on encourt le risque de stagnation économique,
voire de déclin économique,
car il n'y a tout simplement pas assez de clients
pour acheter les produits et les services.
Il est essentiel de se rendre compte
que notre réussite commune dépend de l'accès à l'économie de marché.
Pour visualiser ça, imaginez une personne vraiment exceptionnelle.
Imaginez Steve Jobs, au hasard,
et abandonnez-le tout seul sur une île.
Sur son île, il va tenter de se débrouiller,
en ramassant des noix de coco, comme tout le monde.
Il ne deviendra pas quelqu'un d'extraordinaire.
La raison, bien sûr, c'est qu'il n'y a pas de marché
où épanouir ses talents incroyables.
L'accès au marché est donc crucial en tant qu'individu,
tout comme pour l'ensemble du système en termes de durabilité.
Donc la question devient : que pouvons-nous faire ?
Je pense que nous pouvons envisager ça de façon utopique.
Nous pouvons imaginer un avenir où nous devrons travailler moins,
où nous aurons plus de temps pour nos loisirs,
plus de temps à consacrer à nos familles,
plus de temps pour faire des choses qu'on trouve enrichissantes,
par exemple.
C'est une vision formidable de l'avenir,
que nous devrions essayer d'atteindre sans faute.
En même temps, je pense cependant que nous devons rester réalistes
et nous rendre compte que nous allons probablement
affronter un problème grave de distribution des revenus.
Beaucoup de gens vont rester sur le bord du chemin.
Je pense que pour résoudre ce problème,
nous devrons finalement trouver un moyen
de découpler les revenus du travail traditionnel.
Le meilleur moyen, et le plus direct, à ma connaissance,
est de créer un revenu garanti, un revenu universel.
L'idée fondamentale du revenu universel fait son chemin
commence à attirer l'attention.
Il y a beaucoup de projets pilotes,
et des expériences en cours à travers le monde.
Je pense que le revenu de base n'est pas la panacée.
Ce n'est pas une solution réutilisable partout.
Mais nous pouvons commencer par ça.
C'est une idée que nous pouvons développer et affiner.
Par exemple, j'ai beaucoup écrit au sujet de la possibilité
d'associer des incitations explicites au revenu de base.
Pour illustrer ça,
imaginez que vous êtes un lycéen qui a du mal à s'en sortir
et que vous risquez d'abandonner l'école.
Et pourtant, supposons que vous sachiez qu'à un moment donné,
quoi qu'il arrive,
vous allez gagner le même revenu de base que tout le monde.
À mon avis, cela crée une incitation très perverse
de tout laisser tomber et d'abandonner l'école.
Il ne faut donc pas structurer les choses de cette façon.
À la place, offrons un revenu plus élevé aux diplômés du secondaire
qu'à ceux qui ont abandonné le lycée.
Nous pouvons prendre l'idée d'incitations incluses dans le revenu universel,
et l'étendre à d'autres domaines.
Nous pourrions créer une incitation pour travailler dans la communauté,
pour aider les autres,
ou encore pour avoir un impact positif sur l'environnement
et ainsi de suite.
En intégrant des incitations au sein d'un revenu de base,
nous pouvons l'améliorer,
et tout du moins, prendre quelques mesures
vers la résolution d'un autre problème
qui je le crains, va se poser à nous à l'avenir :
comment allons-nous trouver sens et accomplissement,
et qu'allons-nous faire de notre temps
dans un monde où il y a moins de demande pour un travail traditionnel ?
Donc en prolongeant et en raffinant un revenu universel,
nous pouvons rendre cet avenir meilleur,
et nous pouvons, peut-être, le rendre plus acceptable
politiquement et socialement, et faisable.
Naturellement, en agissant ainsi,
nous augmentons les chances que cela arrive.
Je pense que l'une des objections les plus fondamentales,
presque instinctive,
à l'idée d'un revenu universel disponible pour tous,
et à l'expansion du filet de sécurité,
est liée à notre peur de finir avec trop de personnes
qui bénéficient de la manne économique,
et trop peu pour en supporter la charge.
Le message que j’essaye de faire passer,
c'est que dans l'avenir,
les machines vont être de plus en plus capables de supporter cette charge.
Cela devrait nous donner plus de possibilités
dans le choix des structures de notre société et de notre économie.
Je pense qu'ultimement, ce ne sera plus un luxe,
et que ça va devenir un impératif.
La raison bien sûr, est que tout cela va créer
un tel degré de pression sur la société,
et parce que l'emploi est le mécanisme
qui donne aux consommateurs leur pouvoir d'achat,
qui leur permet de faire fonctionner l'économie.
Si ce mécanisme s'érode à l'avenir,
nous allons devoir le remplacer par autre chose
sans quoi nous serons confrontés au risque que notre système ne soit pas pérenne.
Selon moi, la ligne de flottaison,
pour résoudre ces problèmes,
et surtout trouver un moyen de construire une économie
qui subviendra aux besoins de tous, à tous les niveaux de notre société,
s’avérera l'un des plus importants défis auxquels nous sommes confrontés
dans les années et les décennies à venir.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)